directement dans la brouette grave away
samuel fanny et matteo ne se lasse pas
de ce chantier de restauration depuis
trois ans il consacre une partie de
leurs vacances scolaires à refaire une
beauté à cette petite chapelle du 11e
siècle l'ambiance allait bien et puis on
s'amuse un peu on apprend plein de
choses et nous apprennent aussi des
trucs qu'on connaît pas donc c'est bien
c'était pas appris par exemple ma
démolir un mur juge damon y parvenir
tous les jours donc oui voilà déjà et
puis bah non de faire de l'enduit des
choses comme ça bah je serai pas les
fermes avant donc ils m'ont appris aussi
à l'état qui travaille l'équipe du fou
c'est bien ce matin la mission des
jeunes est de démolir ce mur qui n'est
pas d'origine et de trier les pierres
qui pourront servir à recréer un seuil
dans la chapelle avec un fait et doit
on n'a pas pour but de professionnaliser
les jeunes on les a
pour les
initiés dans la mesure de nos
possibilités
à différents métiers on a fait de la
charpente ont fait de la maçonnerie de
la taille de pierre on a un atelier bois
sont très diversifiés mais le but c'est
pas de cesser de les faire travailler
ensemble
le goûter les petits le moment que vous
attentez
leurs devises ces données avant de
recevoir et donc c'est de travailler
bénévolement et de données donc ils
travaillent pour restaurer mais il
travaille pour ils ont fait des
des créations de mobilier urbain pour
une association de mobilier pour les
jardins des collèges l'idée c'est de
tous les jeunes qu'ils soient soient
travaillent ensemble dans un même
objectif pour participer à ce chantier
les parents paie une participation pour
les repas de 12 euros le matin les
jeunes travaillent sur le chantier et
l'après midi l'association leur propose
des activités de loisirs